one of the problems I run into when
talking to people about symbolism is the
whole problem of the literal versus
metaphor idea and I've talked about this
a little bit before but I think I want
to dive into that problem and show you
guys that in fact you know it isn't very
much of a problem once you realize that
there is no such thing as literal
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
now of course I already hear a bunch of
people screaming no he's saying that
that the Bible didn't happen that these
that everything is just a metaphor
no exactly i'm trying to break that
duality I'm really trying to destroy it
because it is really not useful in
understanding how meaning occurs and how
things manifest themselves now when I
say that there's no such thing as
literal what I mean by literal is this
strange pervasive idea that is still
there in the West it seems that there is
such a thing as a direct description of
something that there is such a thing as
a description of something which is not
bound up in meaning and which is not
bound up in narrative or an image that
it is somehow a descript meaningless
description that there is no it doesn't
it's not it's not already imbibed in
meaning and you you get that all the
time when you talk to people they ask
you you know especially in terms of a
story in terms of the Bible especially
people will argue over whether or not
the description in the Bible are literal
now I to be honest with you at this
point in my life at this point in my
understanding I don't I don't see what
that even means I can understand in the
way that people talk about it what it is
they seem to inferring that it is
somehow a neutral description of reality
that is not in that doesn't already have
value or meaning and late in it but I
don't understand how that is possible
because when you describe something no
matter what it is you describe you have
to describe it you have to have a
purpose to describe it you need a frame
in order to talk about something because
like I've told you a million times in I
keep repeating it's that reality is too
big there are too many details if I
describe a series of events I will use I
will do it with a purpose
to make you understand something - - I
have to focus my attention on something
because around the event that I'm
describing there are a million
other events going on that I'm not
describing and the question is why am i
describing these events and not
describing these other events now
already that harms the problem of this
notion of literal because if I am NOT
talking about you know the fact that
this person if I'm telling a story about
something and I'm not talking about you
know the folds in their shirt where I'm
not talking about you know the fact that
they cut themselves shaving in the
morning you know I'm not talking about
those things because they're not
relevant to what it is that I'm trying
to get you they're not part of the
purpose that I'm the purpose for which
I'm describing something now depending
on the purpose for which I'm describing
something I will use different types of
language to describe it and the idea
that somehow accuracy in the you know
they can this kind of scientific sense
that somehow accuracy is always
desirable is of course completely wrong
it is it is completely absurd because
accuracy also can fall into a an
indefinite amount of detail you know if
let's say that I am describing a fight
and I want you to understand what
happened now I could use a language that
is extremely accurate I could say
something like you know the the guy put
his foot left foot in front of his front
foot and then the other person's right
hand came at this speed towards his face
and he slightly flinched when the the
fist hit his face he displaced so many
hairs and displaced so many pores and
then you know so many tissues in his in
his cheek were were were disturbed and
then the you know his head moved three
centimeters to the left and then it
moved forward four centimeters backwards
and I can go on and on and on and I
could describe extremely accurately the
event but as I'm describing it
accurately I'm not getting to the
purpose that I'm describing the event
for the that I'm describing this event
to you for now I could say something
like
the guy got smashed he know he got
totally his ass got whooped I could use
all this hyperbolic language in order to
help you understand what happened in the
fight and in the end my hyperbolic
language the fact that I'll use
exaggerations that I'll use figures of
speech that I'll use all these different
ways of talking about reality will end
up being truer to the purpose that I'm
using to describe the event than if I
was accurate in describing it now that's
extremely important to understand
especially if we're looking at stories
in the Bible there are ways each story
in the Bible each book in the Bible has
different ways of describing things
which are based on the purpose that they
are describing them for and so there are
different styles different ways there
are different analogies which can be
used in order to help you understand the
the reason for which I am describing the
text and so this very idea that somehow
you can get to this literal description
of reality is extremely problematic and
it's not useful it's better to it's
better to rather understand the purpose
that a story is being for which a story
is being told
even a scientific even a scientific
theory is never literal in the sense of
a neutral description of reality when
you do a scientific experiment you have
to frame that scientific experiment
extremely narrowly because like I said
there are too many details and so if if
my purpose in a scientific experiment is
to prove something about water I will
not give you descriptions of trees or
descriptions of of rocks no I will talk
about the fact the thing that I'm trying
to describe and so that frame will will
be extremely narrow and and I will use a
certain type of language quantifiable
language in order to describe the
phenomena that I'm explaining to you and
the purpose is so that you can
understand the the mechanistic causes
that bring it about and so that maybe
you can
produce it mechanistically but when
we're telling when we're describing an
event
we're don't that's not always the reason
why we're describing it like I said to
using figure as figures of speech and
scan somehow sometimes be more effective
and more powerful than then using just
you know this kind of quantifiable
language now if I use figures of speech
or if I use analogies to describe
something does it mean that I'm not
describing an event of course not of
course I'm still be describing an event
despite the fact that I'm using
different types of ways of explaining it
now the stretch that I'm asking you guys
to make it's very important you know
Christian the Christian persuade of
describing reality is that the world is
made by logos the world is made by
meaning and purpose and all of this and
so the very cosmology in which
Christianity exists excludes the idea
that there could be some kind of neutral
reality that exists at the bottom
somehow and that is not informed by
meaning by logos you know that the Bible
itself describes the creation process as
a process which is full of meaning and
purpose and so I don't understand how
despite that people can somehow still
have this weird idea of this neutral
reality which exists underneath the the
the the world of Christianity is a
meeting of heaven and earth and so it's
a meeting of patterns logos meaning
purpose and this this potentiality which
is there at the bottom you know I may be
you people don't like the word
potentiality you can use another word
st. Maximus talks about logos and Tropos
that is this notion of purpose and
meaning and then the particularity z' of
something those two have to join
together and that that is a little mini
you could call it a mini incarnation
it's not an incarnation in the same way
that Christ is incarnated but it is
analogous to the Incarnation in the
sense that it's an invisible meaning and
purpose which joins a kind of indefinite
particularity and that meaning
that's where reality exists that's where
the world where life where all of these
things are and once that starts to break
in our thinking a lot of things become
less problematic a lot of things become
less difficult to to deal with because
one of the problems that we have is that
people seem to want you know let's say
they're reading the story in Genesis
they're reading the the description of
creation they want to get to this event
they somehow think that they can access
this neutral event which is behind the
story you don't have access to that hope
that you can't get to it because it
doesn't exist it doesn't exist on its
own it the the events that happen as far
as they are described are this framing
this coming together of meaning and
particulars and so what we have is the
story especially when we're talking
about something like the creation story
or the or the you know the these ancient
stories that have been around for
thousands of years what we have is the
story you to try to somehow get to what
is behind the story in this neutral
manner is not the right way to go people
do think that somehow you know they
tried through these archaeological
methods or through these historical
methods to get to what is behind the
story in Genesis but it's a it's a
futile trip and it's also it's
especially futile if you think that once
you get there that what you're going to
get from using archaeological methods or
using these different new scientific
ways of breaking down the text into all
these different you know sources or
whatever people come up with in the
modern world you're not going to get to
something which is truer than what the
story is offering you and once you get
once you understand that then like I
said a lot of things are going to free
up in your mind and a lot of problems
are going to go away one of the one of
the examples that I like to use is the
example of
of the prophecy that that Elijah is
going to come before the Messiah so
there's this prophecy which in the Old
Testament which said that Elijah is
going to come back is going to do it's
going to show himself before the Messiah
so when Christ is there you know the
disciples asked him about this prophecy
can I ask him about what is going on and
Christ tells them that Saint John the
Baptist is the Elijah that was to come
before the Messiah and he says if you're
able to receive this that is what
happened now
now the question that is asked if a
question is posed did Elijah come before
the Messiah the answer is yes Elijah did
come before the Messiah that Elijah was
John the Baptist that you see you see
what I'm doing there I'm not trying I'm
not trying to get to this weird literal
neutral reality behind it I'm trying to
show you how Christ can can quite easily
take the this prophecy and show that
it's actually a pattern of reality which
is manifesting itself and here is the
manner in which it manifest itself
Elijah as this this pattern st. John the
Baptist those two come together and so
the answer to did did Elijah manifest
himself before the Messiah the answer is
yes now that is that is the answer you
give to that I will give to everything
you know did Adam and Eve fall in the
garden yes did Adam and Eve eat the
apple in the garden yes
all of these things I have no problem
saying that they are true and that they
are the best description of that event
and the best description of that reality
I'm not trying to get behind in some
weird scientific sense behind the story
to find out what it is that really
happened I don't know what you're
talking about I have no idea what it
would what it is that you think you're
going to get to that story is the story
that was given to us as the description
of this extremely important event and
the question of how
to describe that story that's it that's
the story that's the story we have and
that's the best way to describe that
event and so like I said a lot of
problems a lot of the difficulties of
modern Christians have is that without
even knowing it they have completely
taken upon themselves the kind of modern
scientific view of the world as being
the highest reality you know I remember
hearing when I was younger a a
Protestant tell me that science is just
the mind of God well that's a serious
problem to engage the world that way
because then you always end up trying to
like I said to get behind the story and
to find some scientific description
which you could find behind the story
well it's not there because science is
not the first the first degree of
reality science is great it's fine you
know like I've always told you guys to
fly airplanes to make medicine it's it's
wonderful and it and it works and it and
it does what it's supposed to do but
that is it is not first of all the only
way to describe reality and it is not
the best way to describe reality if your
purpose is to show people how to live if
your purpose is to help people
understand events that happened so long
ago that all your reference points
aren't even aren't aren't you won't even
be able to connect to the reference
points in the scientific way so we use
we use story tropes manners of
describing that are the best way to
describe that event and so like I said
so because so because of that it is
extremely problematic to say that that
that you can that there this weird
opposition between literal and
metaphorical now there are other people
who somehow think that the metaphor is
going to save them as well that's by
somehow saying that something is a
metaphor is going to get them out of
trouble now this is particularly true of
communion and I've seen this that I've
seen it happen so many times now in
YouTube comments people bringing this up
when I talk about Communion and I talk
about the reality of communion and the
that the that this is truly the body and
blood of Christ now obviously someone
will show up and say no no it's it's not
it that's so disturbing to say that
because it's this weird cannibalistic
thing it's it's just a symbol it's just
a just a metaphor Christ is saying this
is this isn't this is a metaphor for my
body and blood and and so you know so
because of that somehow they think
they're getting out of the problem well
you're not getting out of the problem
because first of all I will not Accord
to you that it is just a metaphor that
is that is such a anyways we will get
into that but let's say that I did let's
say that I gave that to you let's say
that I gave the fact that it's just a
metaphor to you how are you getting out
of the problem so you're saying that oh
no it's so disturbing this idea that we
would eat the real body and blood of
Christ but it's not disturbing that you
would eat the metaphorical body and
blood of Christ like why is that not as
weird and that just as disturbing as
saying that it's real it's like I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be a bit disturbing
right now but let's say that some weird
weird cult came up with a ritual where
they eat the feces of someone or they
eat they they have a kind of inverse
satanic you know communion where they
eat they eat the feces of their their
master or whatever you know and then you
know someone says oh no no no we're not
really eating the feces of our master
it's just it's it's a it's a
metaphorical eating of the feces we just
make this bread in the form of feces and
then we eat it you know it's just a
metaphorical eating of feces it's like
why is that less weird why is that less
disturbing why is that less of a problem
it's the best for you to deal with the
the the mystery or do you can't totally
deal with it but face the mystery of
communion rather than try to skirt
around it and avoid it by thinking that
saying that somehow because you think
that something is just a metaphor it's
meaningless it's not I keep I keep
joking around and you know my brother
and I we always say that it's like
there's
no such thing as literal and there is no
metaphor that's not how that's not how
things work it's not as simple that you
can't just throw something away and say
that oh that's just a metaphor well
there's a reason why you're using that
metaphor even if it's just a metaphor
there's a reason why your your your your
using those words and that purpose even
if it's just literal these these terms
are not useful to help us understand how
meaning occurs in how things unfold now
in terms of communion you know to
understand this problem of the body
let's say and blood not to understand it
but to to deal with it and to deal with
the idea that it's not it's neither
literal in the scientific sense nor is
it a metaphor in the in this disc also
excited I mean modern way of
understanding metaphor that it is
something that is symbolic in the way
that I'm trying to explain it is it is
something which is by the join together
bringing together of elements and just
joining with a spiritual essence that
that is how reality functions now you
could you could get to the same idea of
understanding for example when we say
that that the church is the body of
Christ is that literal or is that a
metaphor what's neither of those it's
not literal and it's not a metaphor it's
a symbolic truth it's it's it's actually
it's a symbolic truth which can help you
understand what a body is what you know
how a body comes together and manifests
something which is above it manifests
something spiritual you know anything
that is a body is also is always an
accumulation of parts now just because
you visually see those parts close
together in your perception does it mean
that they're they aren't parts which are
also separate from each other you know
it's like your body there's a lot of
space between your molecules and and if
you think that that relatively amount of
space between your molecules is not
bothersome but the relatively the big
amount of space between the members of
the church is somehow that's a problem
so now that can't be a body like yes it
can be a body an accumulation of people
can also be a body just like the
accumulation of your molecules can also
be a body and the way that that happens
is neither literal nor is it a metaphor
it is symbolic it is the capacity the
unity of multiplicity which appears to
us shows us that the spiritual essence
the the logos the purpose which makes us
engage with something as one as a unity
so I hope that that's helpful a little
bit in understanding why if you guys
engage with me and and and engage with
you with those types of languages of
literal and metaphorical all of that it
is not it's not useful to help you
understand the world so I hope this is
then this is help and I will get talk to
you guys again very soon if you enjoy
the symbolic world content there's a lot
of things you can do to help us out and
not subscribe please do go ahead and
share this to all your friends if you
can get involved in the discussion we
have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website